if you're on an old episode of room  Raiders what would you be most afraid of  being found being found okay in my room  probably like my dirty underwear for  sure that would be the first thing I  would look to embarrass someone and I  just feel like there have been times  where men have been alone in my house  and I've had this real moment  Jake's dirty underwear  dude a chick's dirty underwear it looks  like when it's on it looks like  Spider-Man got to it it's crazy it is  wild  it's too much I'm like what happened to  me should I call the police every day I  take my underwear off and I go am I okay  it's too much too much going on  I'm like this thing's gonna mold  cut that  I'm never gonna go [ __ ] again